listen to this
this otherworldly sound happens to be a
justin bieber song slowed down 800
percent and it's this contorted version
of the song that was responsible in part
for inspiring what would eventually
become the sound of the batmobile in the
latest batman film
[Music]
this video is sponsored by
curiositystream watch the exclusive
companion video on nebula when you sign
up for the curiosity stream nebula
bundle today watch this clip on mute
a truck passes in front of the frame and
imagine with me for a moment what sound
you think will accompany that truck got
it okay here it is
i must choose my targets carefully
instead of a truck we hear a train but
there's no visual sign of a train in
this shot or any of the shots in close
proximity the film establishes trains as
part of the setting but when the sound
plays we don't see a train the sound of
the train passing fades out as the truck
passes it's almost as if the truck was
making the sound i'm guessing if you've
seen the movie you didn't even notice or
think about this but this small detail
reveals something about sound in film
and especially how it's used in the
batman that i think is fascinating
gotham city in the new batman film is
soaked in rain i don't think i've seen a
film that uses rain this relentlessly
since david fincher's seven which this
movie is obviously drawing some
inspiration from it's impressive the
range of effects and moods that the
sound team for the batman manages to get
out of the sound of the rain this rain
hitting the bat signal at the beginning
almost has a sinister sizzling feel
the rain in this scene feels cold icy
and almost sleet like
the rain in a more intimate setting like
this one
or this one
feels warmer and cozier
and in this scene where batman's doing
some hard-boiled detective investigating
the rain in the background almost sounds
like boiling or simmering water
if you listen closely the rain has a
unique sound in almost every scene or
location in the film and the differences
in the sounds don't just reflect the
fact that rain sounds different in
different environments they actually
design the sound of the rain to
reinforce the mood of each scene i've
talked before about expressionism and
cinematography and similar to how harsh
shadows and lighting and even set design
can become an external manifestation of
a character's internal psychological
state sound can express these things as
well but the way something sounds isn't
the only way you can use sound
expressively the mix of the sound its
volume and the relative volume of
different sound elements in the scene
can be used in an expressionistic way
take this moment
[Music]
if you were standing in a room and it
was raining outside you could hear the
rain and as long as it's still raining
in the real world the volume of the rain
outside isn't going to change but let's
turn down the dialogue in this scene and
i want you to listen closely to what's
happening with the sound of the rain in
the background
[Music]
[Music]
here
the rain which is a prominent part of
the ambient soundscape softens and
almost drops away completely for a
moment to emphasize the tension between
batman and selena before coming back in
towards the end
the mix here is modeling the sound of
the film around the subjective
experience of the characters in the real
world when you're focused in on
something you tend not to pay attention
to the ambient sounds around you they're
still there at a constant volume but
you're not actually hearing them right
now in whatever environment you're
watching this in there are probably all
kinds of external sounds that you
haven't been listening to while you're
listening to me but if i draw your
attention to them like i'm doing now you
probably suddenly become aware of them
in our subjective experience of the
world what we hear reflects what we're
paying attention to so by manipulating
the level of certain ambient sounds the
sound team is placing you as the viewer
inside the character's subjective
perspective
this kind of subjectivity isn't just
created through levels listen to this
moment and pay close attention to the
sound of the camera flashes
he's wearing gloves
friday july 16th
my life has been a cruel riddle i could
not solve hear how they become echoey
and reverby as gordon reads the
riddler's words in this scene we're
inside batman's auditory perspective
here the sound design isn't replicating
a real world effect in how we perceive
sound just like we don't actually see in
slow motion but sometimes
cinematographers use that to create a
subjective effect there's a kind of
dissociative quality to this kind of
echoey effect that helps us understand
the headspace the characters are in in a
film sound's relationship to reality can
be very loose instead of crafting a
soundscape that is realistic sound
designers and engineers have a lot of
leeway in a film to design sounds that
create the right impression of reality
or that reflect a character's subjective
experience rather than what the
environment or the objects would
actually sound like
[Music]
i'm sure we're all familiar with the
idea of score using a motif or theme to
cue a certain character this film
obviously has one for batman that it
employs in sometimes strikingly subtle
ways like in this moment where it
literally only plays the first note of
the theme
as the words the batman appear on screen
we often think of a film soundtrack as
coming from a kind of objective
perspective where the film itself is
telling us what the emotions of the
scene are or what's happening but film
score can be used subjectively as well
in this moment when selena's theme plays
as this boot is revealed the film's
score isn't telling us objectively that
it's selena because it turns out not to
be the film is telling us that bruce
thinks it's selena my favorite
soundtrack cue in the film is the
riddler's ave maria which is used
expertly for this scene
the association between the riddler and
the song is established earlier in the
film and here the fact that the choir
sings it before the riddler shows up
gives the whole scene a sense of
foreboding and suspense but by placing
the music in the scene diegetically
which just means that the sound is
actually coming from within the world of
the film instead of just one that's part
of the omniscient soundtrack it creates
a sense of ambiguity that pervades the
scene the ambiguity doesn't just come
from the song we also hear this sound
which sounds like the riddler's
signature gasp scream thing but then it
ends in a cough
so we're not quite sure if it's supposed
to actually be the riddler or not which
is the entire tension of the scene bruce
is paranoid and is seeing the riddler
everywhere and the film does a great job
of helping us enter into that ambiguity
and mystery through the sound design
one of the interesting auditory tools
that this movie uses kind of exists in
the space between sound effect and
soundtrack listen to this ambient
soundscape it's kind of an underwater
droning and it crops up pretty much any
time riddler is on screen and batman is
looking at or listening to him it's not
a piece of film score but it's also not
really a sound effect it's not motivated
by any element of the environment but
this sound unlike ave maria also isn't a
cue for the riddler it's more of a cue
for batman's emotional response to the
riddler
here that underwater ambience comes in
right after falcone is shot giving us an
early indication that the batman thinks
the riddler is responsible
and then it shifts to the ave maria
theme as that suspicion is confirmed
after the riddler is unmasked and the
batman has a confrontation with him the
next time we see a video of the riddler
that ambient sound bed is absent hey
guys
thanks for all the comments and uh
because the batman's perspective of the
riddler has changed i'm honestly kind of
in awe of the extensive work and
artistry that goes into the sound design
on a film like this it takes entire
teams of people an incredible amount of
work and a lot of thought goes into
crafting every part of how a film like
this sounds and a lot of the techniques
used aren't even intuitive for example
why is this scene so impactful
the sound of the club just seems so
intense and overwhelming well it turns
out to make the scene feel the way it
does the sound team discovered that they
actually needed to make the sound of the
punches quieter compare the sound of
these hits
to these from moments earlier
it's a mild difference but in the mix
these hits are actually quieter than
these here's a modified version of the
scene where i brought up the levels of
some of these punches
it changes the whole feel of the scene
when we're watching a film we understand
the volume of sounds relative to each
other so if the punches in this scene
are clearly audible the music feels way
quieter if we were in the room and the
music was really blaring you wouldn't be
able to hear these hits
another example of this kind of thing is
in this scene where we can clearly hear
the rain but then moments later once
gunfire breaks out
the rain falls away into silence
listen to this modified version where
the sound of the rain remains audible
the gunshots actually sound quieter even
though i haven't changed their level all
i've done is leave the rain at the
volume it was at moments before
the key takeaway here is that almost
nothing you hear in a film like this is
a reflection of reality the sound is
almost entirely impressionistic and
expressionist
the idea is to create a sound that feels
right to the audience not one that would
be accurate if closely examined
because realism isn't the goal you often
can't achieve what you want simply by
going out into the world and recording
real world sounds the batmobile is a
great example of this the sound design
combines the engine sounds from multiple
sources but there's a key ingredient
that comes from a curious place
that's the sound of a bottle rocket
going off supervising sound editor will
files liked the sound and wanted to
incorporate it into the sound design of
the batmobile but it was too short and
felt too quick and small
it was ultimately the same technique
that was used to create this strange
ethereal version of this justin bieber
song that morphed the bottle rocket
sound into the sound of the batmobile
that's in the film
by stretching the same bottle rocket
sound out into different lengths and
then layering those together viles and
his team were able to build the unique
rising scream that helps make the
batmobile reveal so impactful
[Music]
and by modifying a real sound instead of
trying to generate it synthetically
they maintained a physicality and
imperfect quality in the sound that's a
better fit for the film and the
batmobile's grungy dirty aesthetic
subjective perspective plays an
incredibly important role in the story
of the batman and i've been talking
about how that subjectivity is created
through sound but it's also developed in
cinematography in a way i think is
crucial to the story the movie is trying
to tell you can see more about how the
film develops and uses visual
perspective in the companion video i've
made exclusively available on nebula
nebula is a streaming platform created
by and for independent content creators
like myself on nebula you can watch
every video from me and a ton of other
amazing creators early and without any
ads or sponsorships but you also get
access to a bunch of exclusive nebula
content like my video on perspective in
batman or my video on the sound design
in dune which goes into some of the cool
uses of surround sound mixing that i
don't talk about in this video and now
you can also get an entire bonus episode
of my podcast cinema of meaning where
tom and i discussed 1917 it's available
exclusively on our nebula feed
and here's the best thing you can get
nebula for less than 15 for an entire
year when you sign up for the curiosity
stream plus nebula bundle when you sign
up for the bundle using my link not only
are you getting all the great nebula
content i talked about but you also get
access to curiosity stream which is a
streaming service with thousands of
great educational and documentary titles
you can get all of this today for 26
percent off when you sign up by going to
curiositystream.comthomasflight
or by clicking the link on the screen
[Music]